dear colleagues
today was a great day for us one of our
biggest packages of our mandate was
adopted by college
several commissioners called it a legacy
moment for this college
and france timmermans called it epic
the package that will enable us to
deliver on the european green deal
it would not be here without you
and i would like to thank you from the
bottom of my heart
for the colossal work you've put in this
package
i mean this was months of reflections
weeks of discussions nights of drafting
and hours and hours spent adjusting
every detail so every percentage
you name it your collective effort
has crafted one of the most ambitious
policy packages the european union has
ever seen
it is a complete transformation of our
economy
to help make europe climate neutral by
2050
and with the excitement and the
exhaustion
of the day it is difficult to
quite grasp the significance of what
we've achieved today
but let's be clear today we
showed the whole world that europe was
ready to lead the way
and this was team commission at its best
a whole of commission operation for
whole of society transformation
and i would like to think in particular
our colleagues
from the if i may call them frontline
dgs
for this package dg klima
dg move
dg tagsuit dg envy
dj agri digi trade
and of course the sec gen who invested
tremendous
work in these 13 instruments
and thank you to dg com colleagues for
their efforts to communicate this
package to citizens
i am also very grateful to my team for
their hard work
on this and to all the cabinets and all
members of the college members
you have helped sharpen the analysis
the calibration the presentation so that
we get the right balance
i am very proud of what we achieve
together
and of what we will achieve together
i know more work is ahead of us to
negotiate this package
with the european parliament and the
council and above
all to convince citizens that this
is the right thing to do
but first of all after this intense work
i wish you a nice and relaxing holiday
i hope you can enjoy the summer with
your loved ones
and thank you very much